[Music]
good evening of welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we want to begin this
evening with a quiz quick what does the
Democratic Party stand for they used to
be an easy question to answer for a
hundred years the answer was higher
wages and better benefits that was back
when the Democratic Party was run by
people who worked for a living they
cared about how much voters got paid at
the end of the week that's not a subject
that interests the decadent rich very
much the private equity billionaires who
fund today's Democratic Party could care
less about other people's wages what
they care about most other than making
themselves even richer is feeling
virtuous feeling like deeply good people
much better than you are and that's why
they're so committed to something called
diversity a concept that nobody is
willing to explain but that nonetheless
we must celebrate enthusiastically and
perpetually listen to Nancy Pelosi
explain our diversity is our strength
diversity is our strength
our diversity is our strength I always
say the diversity is our strength and I
say to the caucus our diversity is our
strength and the fact is is that our
diversity is our strength
okay got it
diversity is our strength they've made
that part crystal clear what it's still
unclear is what exactly diversity is
what is it well for one thing diversity
is the reason that Allison jazz Lowe was
forced to resign her job in disgrace
until 24 hours ago jazz law was the
executive director of the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee then
yesterday she quit in tears she asked
her colleagues to forgive her as she
packed her things
what did jazz load do wrong well nothing
actually she didn't hurt anyone she
didn't say anything awful she didn't
miss manage the office nobody claims she
did jazz lows only sin was having the
wrong skin color on Sunday two
congressional Democrats Vicente Gonzales
and Philemon availa demanded that jazz
will be fired from her job and replaced
by a person of a different hue not a
more competent person they didn't
mention that that was irrelevant just a
different colored person that
all that mattered to them so the
Forester person out of her job for
having the wrong genes apparently none
of this set off any alarm bells over at
Democratic Party HQ apparently nobody
could think of any other time in history
or something like this had happened it
didn't seem ominous to them or creepy
racist it just seemed like diversity
which we must celebrate because it's our
strength that actually happened the
Democratic Party has gone insane now you
may think you already knew that but even
if you think you knew it it's hard to
appreciate just how real it is just how
crazy the party has become the party of
ordinary Americans has become a
poisonous identity cult obsessed with
questions of racial purity it's
terrifying but it's entirely real how
real is it well Al Sharpton is now a
hero on the left that kind of sums it up
for 40 years Sharpton chased one hustle
after another race pimp FBI informant
corporate shakedown artist tax cheat if
you told Al Sharpton in 1995 that
someday he'd be the moral conscience of
the Democratic Party he would have
laughed in your face and yet here we are
and here he is sermonizing on MSNBC this
is race baiting at his best this is
donald trump playing the race card and
it is a shame and it is a sham he's
playing a race baiting crap but he's
playing a race divisive card he should
not continue to try and sell this racist
behavior to try and make the country
more divided for his own political gain
there you have it
al Sharpton the man who once attacked
Jews and crackers as parasites bemoaning
our divided nation hilarious but leading
Democrats don't appear to get the joke
just today poor ol Joe Biden tweeted
this quote the Reverend Al is a champion
in the fight for civil rights sure if
the fight for civil rights is a
euphemism for buying more $10,000 suits
in which case Al Sharpton is a
legitimate hero in that fight the
Democratic candidates seem to think he
is watch them kiss his ring at an event
this spring the head of Nan who is truly
right now the steward of the ongoing
movement for civil rights and justice in
our country and that's the Reverend Al
Sharpton in the fight against racism and
for social justice I'll thank you so
much for all that you're doing people
like Reverend Sharpton who has never
stopped fighting for social justice and
Rev I cannot thank you enough for your
years of friendship your years of
leadership I want to say to Reverend Al
Sharpton thank you for leading thank you
for speaking out thank you for showing
us away there you have it the modern
Democratic Party so distorted by race
guilt that Al Sharpton seems like a
moral leader this is nuts
it's also a recipe for an electoral
wipeout there's a lot about the
Democratic Party's economic platform
that ordinary voters might like but this
kind of garbage
it's a deal-killer and not just
conservative white voters no normal
person of any color will vote for stuff
like this
whatever his many faults former Chicago
Mayor Rahm Emanuel does understand that
this week Emanuel published a memo aimed
at the party's presidential candidates
he begged them to return to reality
immediately here's part of it quote
before our party promises health care
coverage to undocumented immigrants a
position not even Ted Kennedy took let's
help them more than 30 million Americans
who are a single illness away from
financial ruin before we start worrying
about whether the Boston Marathon bomber
can vote
let's stop states that are actively
trying to curtail voting rights of
citizens and before we promise a
guaranteed minimum income to healthy
adults who prefer to stay home and play
video games let's increase the minimum
wage and the Earned Income Tax Credit to
the benefit of the millions of people
who still work hard and live near
poverty end quote there were times in
the memo that a manual sounded like
Donald Trump in 2016 for example
American taxpayers have spent the last
20 years both in blood and treasure
building roads schools and hospitals in
Iraq and Afghanistan
all the while American wages continue to
stagnate people are tired of being
treated as chumps it's time to invest in
America again it goes on like this
Emanuel Rambo is full of good advice and
not just good advice for Democrats Memon
wasn't right about everything obviously
but at least it focuses on the right
things
most Americans actually aren't obsessed
with race they don't want to memorize 60
new genders there aren't 60 new genders
there are two genders and everyone knows
it they don't think it's their duty to
give American citizenship to everyone on
the planet along with health care come
on
instead they have a more basic hope and
it's the hope of people everywhere they
want to feel that the country they were
born in is their home they want leaders
who put their interests first leaders
who actually care about their well being
and yet weirdly for decades Washington
has refused to supply leaders like that
that's why Donald Trump won in 2016 it's
why he could very easily win again in
2020 because in the end Americans will
always pick a flawed leader over a
leader who openly hates them every
single time